[Applause]
we used to love me
now you want me to suck on
there was a time when I made it after it
but now my goal here is to share are
used to be the Clown Prince of college a
[Music]
natural lab and they you kids don't
understand why your parents like their
the fact that my dad we're still kinda
in this i-beam but if you happy but the
water boys thought Little Nicky socked
robots made you throw up public be
mostly share and jack-and-jill the
cinematic die thing on your dare I did a
few serious fear didn't get the but you
thought I was okay but I rather speak to
crappy flaws that were popular in ninety
years
tell me if you recognize any of these
murky underdog beats a hot attractive
babe but some hot Bonnie bullies trying
to stop my goofy way my quirky psychic
and her grandma helped me on my path
while using an annoying noise and drop
the papaya come on guys you like to the
first 18 time surely you like it 56-mile
happened today I make you laugh when
you're a 99 day now you treat me like I
turn
and Rob Schneider worm hey thanks buddy
but you forgot to put me in pixels well
that's because you'll in do blackface
for me seriously Sandler even I have
standard
[Music]
I don't know why I've angered all of you
he's God save me or to Transylvania ooh
I do the same thing that I've been doing
for years so what does change now who
gives me all this
[Music]
no don't you see even your idiot
characters from the past who figured it
out your audience has thrown up but you
yourself have not thrown off they talk
about doing a lot of it your audience
have discovered new things so you must
discover new things evolve your craft
try something different
use your movies more than just an excuse
to go on vacation I mean look at your
latest publicity photo
Limburg are sick of you try I see what
you're saying I should be even more
predictable no more on funny I
definitely didn't say that even more
racially insensitive Christ I'm just
gonna sit down by Rob Schneider can you
do reference can I
[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm gonna stealth guy remember it
so you don't have to well ever since I
did my clipless review of Jurassic world
a lot of people have been requesting me
to do another recent movie and
surprisingly it wasn't fifty Shades of
Grey
thank God hey come on ball gags are
surprisingly comfortable how would you
know research know that movie is the
Adam Sandler non hit pixel left and
right people have been asking me to
review this and at first I didn't really
get why okay there is a nostalgic value
seeing how it ties into video games of
the 80s
and I have ripped apart several Adam
salmon productions in the past but I
think the real reason is it was the
worst reviewed films of the year the
internet has gone insane with how much
they hate this movie it's this year's
Fantastic Four
I mean before this year's Fantastic Four
yeah it looked bad but 17 percent bad
that's lower than water boy that's my
boy and Little Nicky Jesus it's worse
than those that's like having Hitler and
then finding out there's a mega Hitler a
Hitler that did even worse than Hitler
and wasn't funny so without further ado
let's take a look at my Futurama
Futurama Futurama Futurama Futurama
future Rob yes let's first address what
everybody's already talking about how
similar this concept is to an episode of
future Rob despite the movie being based
on a short film there's an episode of
Futurama where video games from the 80s
attack their city that's pretty damn
close in comparison to this but I'm
choosing to judge this on its own merits
because much like osmosis jones and
inside out even if it's been done before
what matters is what they can bring to
it that's new and good and Adam Sandler
movies are so the exact opposite of this
that there's actually an app for it now
where is oh yeah it's called the Apple
or Sandler his films are actually so
easy to make now that you can literally
phone them in let's see a normal boy
Sandler or annoying voice am i rather
rub my balls on a cheese grater than
listen to its annoying noise it is let's
see bland huh
your friend a really bland hot
girlfriend what's the difference one get
the crying scene no just that one you
got it wait what are those oh those are
add-ons that come to matter what Kevin
James suckered in celebrities pity
cameos from SNL alumni the only thing
left to choose is funny or unfunny oh my
god I never do we have a choice she was
funny man all right Jesus Christ why
don't you throw so much time effort and
money into something if you're clearly
not gonna make it funny
you painfully obvious metaphor
[Music]
it starts off with the younger versions
of Adam Sandler and Kevin James and an
arcade competition where we insert
Sandler app number 162 sweet old lady
who delivers our first big zinger that
was the first joke people
she says you who were holding up a
bottle of yoohoo a hundred and ten
million dollar budget and that is their
opening joke you know won't you just be
honest and say Sandler loses to a kid
named Eddie which means Eddie's game
play will be put in a time capsule and
launched into space this brings us to
present day when Sandler app number two
to nine down that aslak has been who
people think will amount to nothing it's
having a conversation with Sandler at
four six five supportive best friend and
binge drinking idiot Kevin James who is
President of the United States yeah even
they have to and handle something that
dumb Kevin James is President of the
United States oh shit
in the country that's actually kind of
considering electing Donald Trump as our
next president even we can't be fuckin
stupid enough to accept this as a
reality and the weird thing is he still
plays it as the idiot best friend like
he always does he doesn't act like a
president at all which is why just give
me an idea about how lazy this is I'm
gonna switch out Kevin Jeanes with Obama
now tell me if this makes any sense
whatsoever no Adam Bernie please Emma
totally different character that
yes sure so Adam I'd like to get drunk
while helping my loser friend in a bar
but I need to overcome this outburst
ahead while screaming at schoolchildren
because I can't read that's really in
our movie that's really in our movie
sure you be doing like presidential
stuff that kind of thing oh I do like
when our country's under attack I make a
king with my wife that can be an arm on
page twenty two plants in our movie I'll
give you a call and I need you to
replace our military if you're still in
the theater folks is
Sandler then goes to a customer's house
to fix their TV but finds the owner
played by Michelle Madigan is crying in
the closet while sipping champagne out
of a sippy cup yeah a sippy cup oh is
that your kids no he's 12 then why do
you have how dare you
I can never see us becoming a couple
ever okay who's the fucking idiot who
keeps falling for this the couple that
act alike they're not gonna get together
but everybody else in the world knows
are gonna get together
who's the one fucking idiot who keep
falling for this and encourages this
cliche there's one lesson please call to
the White House as Samba rap 143 takes
place of the huge romantic coincidence
that monoghan happens to be lieutenant
colonel insert Saved by the Bell
commercial here hey hey we're not done
yet we're not done yet now Adam our
military was subject in a way that was a
very similar to a video game as you know
no one in our American intelligence has
ever played a video game yeah earns and
games often don't mix you are the only
person who can figure out these patterns
that people online I figured out years
ago I personally only watched peopIe in
my life you know I like to keep
listening but I just want emphasize more
what a gosh darn great misunderstood
guys Sandler is we need a bully let's
see here jock snob businessman popular
kid watching Brian Cox I can't
understand is one-dimensional dialogue
but thankfully there is a future where
you can just insert all the bully
dialogue from all these other movies you
are a loser and weird you are different
from us which makes you bad you're
marching to a different from we'll leave
we're now get out of here you puppy died
dreamer before I hammer in some more
town from diam and how beautiful you are
but don't worry we can't see Sandler
it's too much of a loser so the app
comes with unrealistic overcompensating
ly pathetic best friend and I know it's
the actor who played the Snowman from
frozen and not the actual snowman from
frozen but I'm choosing him because the
only funny thing they have in common is
that you want to see them both in pink I
spent 30 years wishing a video game
character would come to life and make
love to me just like my fan base now
let's teach them that sitting on your
lazy ass playing video games can somehow
make you a hero I think this calls for
some mundane gibberish so the aliens
misinterpret the time capsule and think
it's an act of war
therefore Sandler and unfunny pervert
instruct the soldiers about how to
defeat them but of course when they
finally attack nobody listens do not
listen to him even though we are
supposed to we are military and not
trained to follow orders what salmon
grabs a gun and starts shooting him up
like an action hero because playing us
at home is clearly the same thing is
fighting in the field and he kills them
all off proving that Adam Sandler is in
fact better than the military
host unorthodox this calls for a party
where the president chugs the hell out
of everybody mr. president don't you
think we should try communicating with
the aliens to negotiate out of any
further trouble no now's the time to
chug beer being the overweight
rambunctious white man that I am again I
took some liberties here it's my job to
go to Ted Kennedy on this beer knowing
another threat is on the way they call
in Eddie's the gaming champion from
years ago played now by Peter Dinklage
only seeing how he's in a Sandler movie
all his talent has to be Shyamalan in
Reverse okay look you know how in a
Shyamalan film you take something that's
not funny and you make it funny yeah
well in an Adam Sandler movie you take
something that's funny and you make it
not funny
oh thanks buddy the app also allows the
uncomfortable moment of silence that
follows every unfunny joke that is never
filled with laughter
whores peeing and fucks draw it out
happy mass and still think the audience
is laughing at this
Christ this is too awkward even for me
and I'm Shyamalan
[Applause]
you
so the final challenge is chasing
pac-man in the city as Sam lair pervert
and dinklage represent that goes in cars
as monoghan advises them from the
sidelines okay why in this universe does
being good at pac-man suddenly translate
into being good at driving would you
really trust your fate in the hands of
pervert II throw man I'm funny cuz I
don't make you laugh
we didn't make more sense if the
lieutenant colonel the one that's been
in the field was driving and Sanders men
the people that just been watching on a
stream we're advising women that just
add up more no no no you don't want that
you're Lions because I gotta be the hero
so you can't really tell you that
seriously but the reason that doesn't
work Sandler is because you act like
you're taking it so seriously like look
at the scene after you defeat pac-man
you're clearly supposed to feel for this
romance because it goes on for fucking
ever and there's no laughs if you want
to go full silly fine then leave out the
serious romance leave out the generic
bully leave out the complicated rules
you're making up for this world because
they clearly don't make any sense these
are so poorly written we can't tell when
you're supposed to be funny you're
supposed to be real no no it's okay
there's a special feature on the app
that lets you know when you're supposed
to take me seriously and whether or not
it's actually a musical app yeah you
listen to the music it lets you know
it's cuz I've actually heard it so many
times my personality actually kind of
changes along with it I don't know if
she'll ever love me
maybe we're just meant to be apart
come on guys we're gonna go get my
girlfriend back who said that was
flirting I didn't say I was flirting
I'm gonna win the championship and save
Grimm huh
so music - tell us how to feel does that
mean you're gonna finally give me a
funny line don't ever ask me that again
tickle it you put the alien claim that
Earth cheated not playing by the
videogame rules and unleash all their
pixelated characters on the world I can
answer that I enter the cheat code to
teleport my car and the last challenge
like I did years ago defeat wait can I
take this one
it's fucking kidding me no seriously are
you fucking kidding me
first of all how did you enter a cheat
code and a championship did none of
these hundreds of people there see you
enter it second of all where did you
enter it your fucking car you have a
control panel on your wheel or did you
just hop fucking Morse code at them
third of all there's a red one
you can't teleport your car or enter
cheat codes in real life we all say yes
to this script we wanted our names on
this okay we just like hug it out a bit
I just need to know that we're gonna
survive all of this hey look everyone
I'm doing the robot instead of
responding appropriately to hostile
alien life and now we reached the part
of the app that nears the end of every
Adam Sandler movie giving up yep
they just give up you know how in most
movie climaxes that's where they try
their hardest well here that's where
they tried their least in fact there's
even a game on the app that simply
titled the lazier the writer the faster
the paycheck this is where you add up
how many times the writer clearly didn't
give a shit and just worked out anything
he wanted to get his paycheck a little
faster let's take a look the aliens gave
several trophies earlier one of them
being Qbert and only now several days
later think to ask him anything about
their alien race so what's the history
of your species ask for it watch me win
call of duty aliens attack full force
with all the pixelated characters
witches need but they make it clear that
when they touch something it turns into
pixels but then when a crane stops
Frogger
nothing happens but really who gives
this shit when the president comes out
and says this they want
in a bunker I said no thanks instead I'm
gonna fight video game aliens and uh
save the world actually that'd be pretty
cool if Obama really did that but he
didn't it was Kevin James put him back
in there yeah your president paul blart
is gonna shoot up a hill again someone
give me a beer to jog now that's the
stupidity I'm used to
it's like Independence Day only that was
hilarious and this is unfunny perverts
video game character he fantasized over
comes to life except she's not pixely
she looks just like a real person there
is no reason for this yeah and despite
were not talking at all if she also
falls in love with the unfunny pervert
fairies again no reason for this both I
try the closer my money gets to me so
the aliens send a CG Max Headroom that
somehow looks even more fake than the
original Max Headroom to solve our
heroes for one last challenge again
really no reason at all to get them a
chance to win but once again they have
to play by the game's rules so what do
our heroes do they cheat and don't play
by the game's rules remember I've seen
earlier saying how cheating was bad well
that's exactly what they do except it
ends up winning the day the only reason
it's ok here it's good to make Adam
Samurai look good
let's talk it I'm almost rewarded for my
incredible gift
this means all the pixels disappear
including unfunny pervs love but it's
okay because cube returns the door this
is so blatantly lazy that even Sandler
himself shrugs off how little this makes
sense but doesn't give a shit nobody
questions why Cupid suddenly thousands
of riders
to preserve our comedic masterpiece
we're taking down every video on Vimeo
that has the word pixels in the title
yes we really did that work insane
we know what you want that was excellent
one of the most hated films of the year
is it one of the worst if not the worst
Adam Sandler production that has ever
been put together no it's not even close
really there are so many other films
that he's had a hand in they have tried
less and accomplished less than this has
there's one or two neat effects and
every 20 minutes maybe I had a little
bit of a laugh which is more than I
could say for some of its other
productions so why is there so much hate
why does this one get people just so
fucking pissed off because it's 20
fucking 15 the fact that Sandler is
still using these lazy gimmicks with no
changes is just becoming insulting even
if you don't like his humor which is
totally understandable
you felt like he was at least trying you
felt like even though it was weird there
was some form of effort being put into
his work before here it's like a hundred
and ten million dollar autopilot
we know Sandler as well as all the
people here can be both talented and
funny but as so many comedians are
trying to evolve in a debt with the
times
samurai seems bizarrely disinterested in
getting better
I think we're angry because we want to
like pixels we want to like Sandler's
work and when we find it's not only bad
but feels uncaring ly bad we wonder why
nobody's waking up after all these bonds
and saying let's try something different
let's step up our game step up our joke
step up our characters this is the
tipping point where people are just
saying enough is enough
Cuba's effort again give us energy
give us something that feels fresh and
new similar to the first surreal time
that we've ever encountered you until
then we still have the sandler app and
hopefully there'll be a day where this
will no longer be a requirement in any
of his films I'm the Nostalgia Critic
and come back I never was
[Music]
yeah you're president paul blart is
gonna shoot up a Hilliard's
[Music]